Are all the goals simeltaneously achieviable in
a given operating system? At first glance
it would seem that some of the goals conflict with one another. For example, it
might seem that to achieve performance, we
may have to sacrifice protection and/or flexibility. Let's
explore how researchers have used their ingenuity
to have the cake and eat it too.
>> You're probably wondering how the commercial
operating systems that you and I use on
an every day basis Meet many of these goals that I identified. The short answer
to that question is they don't meet all the goals. We will return to the
influence of research leading up to the current
state of the art in operating system structure
towards the end of this course module.